tony's camera froze this is what
happened people on live tv that's why i
love live you never know what the hell
is going to happen you just got to roll
with it
so i'm going to do tony's talk of the
table tony spoke with voters in key
battleground states including
in macomb county michigan so as part of
our series at america's crossroads we
wanted to see what gets voters worked up
and tony quickly realized it doesn't
take a whole lot
excuse me sir every presidential
election we journalists try to get the
so-called
pulse of the voters can we ask you a
couple questions but this year we
decided to take that
literally asking republicans and
democrats what's got them riled up
and then measuring the results donald
trump has been saying that he saved the
auto industry
it's not true it's not true you have
several plants that have closed under
his administration
i will say you went up to 105 there
to do it we put pulse readers on the
fingers of voters in macomb county
michigan
carefully wiping down the equipment in
between uses and following cdc
guidelines
then we talked politics what motivates
you in 2020
peace and love right i love america i
love americans
and i'm supporting trump because i think
he will do
what's best for america and all
americans
doug who declined to provide his last
name started with a resting heart rate
of about 104 beats per minute perhaps
only a little elevated by the street
corner rally going on behind him
there's going to be an election and
there's going to be a president
and after that's done we still have to
love each other and still be americans
and we have to stop dividing
you are spiking here as you talk about
the need for love over division you're
at about 139
yeah that's a high for the day actually
and it wasn't always the candidates but
the issues that got hearts pounding
student loan debt you have student loan
debt
i have a lot of student loan debt you're
worried about it i have more student
loan than i have in the mortgage of my
house
wow you started in the low 80s and then
just now talking about
student loans and went back up over 100
about 106.
we need to start paying attention to
climate change because i think it's like
the coronavirus
where we know it's coming but we're not
acting on it
he went up to 112 so that was your
second highest but heart rates can also
fall
and in fact with two voters we found
their pulses actually decreased when
talking about something
that made them feel discouraged how do
you feel when the president talks about
race relations in this country
i think it's sad you know to me it's
something that we should be
all trying to come together when talking
about the president's coronavirus
response for example
felicia dorsey fair's pulse hovered in
the 80s
but when we asked her about race it
dropped your pulse goes down
consistently when you talk about these
social justice issues
i'm tired of the anger i'm tired of the
division don beatty on the other hand
well she got going fast and never dipped
once
coronavirus restrictions seem to set her
off the most this is supposed to be a
free country and i'm not feeling very
free right now you're jumping into the
130s now yeah you start to live already
what makes you most upset when you think
of 2020
i mean 2020 has been a dumpster fire
so guys i don't know if you can see me
but if you can i will say i am not a
doctor and that was some super
unscientific reporting we just did right
there nonetheless
i thought it was pretty revealing yeah
it's a great way to look at what's going
on
very well done tonight it sure was all
right thanks tony